this is the test version of BMWs new
hybrid I eight sports car but she's not
quite ready for the press
this is Beijing after all she needs a
bath first
Oh
wait where are the chamois girls
now she's ready for my road test quiet
is whisper the engine hasn't kicked in
yet the electric engine of course is
driving it we can switch to the all gas
version by moving it into sport now look
at this it's already telling us we're
burning gas and then there it goes
here that that's the hybrid engine
kicking in BMW obviously has a head
start in the China market compared to
Tesla whether that gives the Germans and
the BMW i8 an advantage over the Model S
is yet to be seen but let's check out
the hybrid I ate from BMW obviously to
gull wing doors this is the electric
test vehicle so it's not really the
production commercial model just yet you
can see here look at this carbon-fiber
body so it's fairly light and in the
front is the electric engine and this is
the charging station now you can see
just fairly straightforward just plug
and play the range anxiety though is
something to be considered especially in
Beijing because we don't have these in
the high-rise buildings you're going to
have to have a pretty long extension
cord up to your 30th floor apartment but
this car the good thing I guess is it's
a hybrid so it has both an electric
engine in the front and then a
twin-turbo 3 cylinder peppy engine in
the back petrol engine that will get you
they say 0 to 60 in 4.5 seconds an i8 is
a sports car when you put it in to zero
mission mode yes of course you can drive
3035 kilometers or so but as soon as
that battery starts to run down the
engine will automatically start to
recharge it and of course give you a lot
of additional power the BMW i8 may be
environmentally friendly but it's not
too economically friendly so we at
Bloomberg want to show both sides of the
story
beebeep
see you later so welcome to the China
market model s and I ate if we are
indeed in a bubble here you'll likely
have some competition at opposite end of
the electrified spectrum Steven angle
Bloomberg meeting